this is one everyone's been begging us
to talk about all week okay hot sauce
drink
fam
hot sauce break
fam
how can she
have the gall to say she wants to sue
dare you
how i dare you i'd let her take me to
court for that how
big man you've come into my hotel i've
banged you i've nothing in a dom i've
gone to flush it or do whatever i need
to do i've gone to the bathroom you're
unbeknownst you then have the balls to
go to my bathroom look for my dom steal
my seeds steal my seed slide it in your
vag and be pissed that it's burning you
and you want to sue me fam you're a
thief yeah fm you're a thief you're a
[ __ ]
you're a scumbag you're the lowest of
the low i couldn't believe what i was
reading james fam oh sorry for people
who aren't aware yeah obviously sorry
yeah
so basically there was an article that
came out still to this day no one knows
if it's true or not it's true yeah i
reckon it's probably true it's very
specific
the reason why i know it's true because
um
drake has got a bar i can't remember
what song it is
talk about flushing the side yeah
because people trying to yeah yeah and
you're saying to get the maid to clean
up the whole room but i can't remember
what track it is one of these recent
tracks anyway but continue yeah so
basically uh came out that uh drake
banged some ig model i need to know
which one i bet she was far
that he loves these
women bbw yeah he loves it um that one's
get off me get off music yeah yeah so
brought back to the hotel
um
they had sex
he obviously used a condom he then took
the condom into the bathroom
put hot sauce in it to kill the sperm
and then put it in the bin
when he wasn't looking the girl ran in
stole the condom and tried to insert
herself with his nut not knowing there's
hot sauce in there and burnt her vagina
black and blue
um and now she's trying to sue drake for
whatever reason i don't know i can put
hot sauce where i want one it's my yard
mine not my dom i can do what i want
with it how dare you try and sue me
it's my turn with my night in it i can
literally do whatever i want i could
never be the judge listening to this i
would look at her like what do you think
this is i'd make her ever waste my time
yeah i'd make her pay him you'd have to
don't waste my time like this again
everyone's time you're a joke you're a
joke and you wanted a quick buck that's
what you wanted i reckon the only reason
she's suing him is because if it is true
the only reason she's suing him is
because she thinks he'll settle out of
court because he doesn't want to deal
with he hasn't got the time
how much do you want what 20 bags yeah
yeah 20 bags just [ __ ] off take it yeah
but out of principle for that one alone
i feel like this is one of like take me
to take me david take me because you're
gonna lose everything
you're gonna lose everything you're
gonna lose everything bro um
but everyone
my name is a minute about this i've seen
so many memes so many skits about just
[ __ ] hot sauce this hot stuff like
getting churches in the hot sauce thing
is as well this is what
men are so fickle and so eager for the
dub they need a win but women will
as soon as this comes out anyway if they
haven't already fought by women will
easily use this to like expose men okay
and just in terms of like i imagined
like
imagine like obviously this is the play
that they're using now our hot sauce
but obviously dre
drake is drake and you're not drake yeah
standard standard yeah so it's a thing
where like i can imagine like
you chatting to a couple girls et cetera
et cetera you're with your man's
everything's blessed in the bar and just
like yeah yeah yeah yeah come come come
come and you're like a little liquid
joking like hey
my my mama where's my hot sauce
yeah yeah all these [ __ ] are down
where's the hot sauce
fam
i can you can you can see a girl being
like
hot sauce look at your hairline
look at your hairline and man's talking
about he needs hot sauce
let's talk about in his hot sauce
he can't even afford a starter and he
thinks i'm teeth in his shoes big but no
one wants you trust me you don't need
hot sauce
how tall are you
the second the follow-up the follower
he's speechless how tall are you i was
speechless for what you said look at
your hair look at your hairline look at
your beard and look at your height and
man's talking about he needs hot sauce
joke tea
tea
i'm getting them together
in his house
not sauce
look at his hair like i said he needs
hot sauce oh anyone's trying you
couldn't pay me to have your you oh
you couldn't pay me
and make seniors hot sauce you're a joke
that would
that would break me as a human being
women are relentless that would break me
as a human being i don't think you can't
make two two jokes i don't think you
can't hit me with the hairline bar as
well as the height bar in the same
conversation
you could never
man said he wants hot sauce
look at your hairline bro
man said look how tall are you again how
tall are you
five what you lost me
you lost me at five fam
you lost me trust me you could leave
your dom on my pillow you're safe
trust me you're safe
wow
i know women would use that as an excuse
because i've seen
men are getting too comfortable yeah
yeah because it's the only dub you've
got in a while it's the only dub as a
collective as a group as a society of
men this is the only dub we've had in a
while he is you know i don't see men
winning anywhere else no we're not they
they can't have that
women can't let us have one well not one
dove they've got 99. they've got all of
them we can't have one we're not allowed
any hot sauce yeah they're chatting in
the group chat these men are getting
carried away with this hot sauce
fam group chat screenshot
one story screenshot and they're
bullying you
that knows he's talking about hot sauce
that is hilarious wow that's hilarious
like say i'd ever get a dime out of his
busted ass
you can't get away with it you can't
thumb i swear you wear a uniform to work
hot sauce
wow
that's interesting
oh
you don't need that maiji yeah trust me
fam you don't need hot sauce damn no one
wants anything to do with you oh that
was a bullet jesus christ